hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others i'm happy to try and
both address specific questions and talk
about general topics
i see that there are all kinds of
questions left over from
before uh let's see where should we
start
start with one from wave the question is
about large language models like gpt-3
how they work and how to ask the right
questions okay so let's talk about what
this is all about
so
in the modern world of artificial
intelligence ai and machine learning
one of the areas that's been very
popular
is
dealing with human language
and
one of the ideas the idea of things like
gpt-3
is it is a particular example of a
neural network that has been trained to
generate
natural language
and
it's
essentially what the way it's working is
that it's been given billions of
examples of
if this piece of text
of different pieces of text
and it's it's trying to learn from
example so it says if the piece of text
said
uh the
the earth is
uh
i don't know
round or something
um
let's say the earth is blank but not
flat and not flat
then
there's a very good chance that in all
those examples of text that it's picked
up that there'll be
quite a few that say the earth is round
but not flat let's say so what is going
on is this neural net is learning from
examples what are typical words that get
filled in in typical places
and
so what is being done is
there's so there's lots and lots of text
particularly from the web there's a few
billion pages of text on the web for
example i'm not sure that's specifically
where gpt3 was trained but there's
there's lots of text out there and
available in the world and so the
question is can you
have something that learns from those
examples and tries to reproduce things
that are like those examples
how does it work inside
well
it uh
it's
essentially what's happening is it's
making
a kind of a program
that
is set up so that it says if you've seen
this then the chances are you will see
that later so for example how would you
make such a program let's take it at the
very simplest level with english
if you see a queue in an english
sentence or an english word there's a
very good chance it's going to be
followed by you
if you see
a
th for example
there's a decent probability that it's
going to be followed by an e with the
word v for example there might be some
other things that might be followed by
so the very simplest thing one could
imagine doing is just trying to learn
uh given a letter
what's it most likely to be followed by
in the case of q it's it's rather
obviously you in the case of other
things it might be
different probabilities for different
letters so the first thing one could do
is one takes a big sample of english and
one just looks at every letter and one
looks at what follows it and that gives
one a thing that will tell one
the chances are if you have a q it'll be
followed by you so now if you're in it
trying to use the system to generate
a word for example if it generates a
queue then it pretty much knows it's
going to put a u after it
so you can generalize that idea by
working out if you see this particular
word it's most likely to be followed by
this word
in the the the model that gets made the
program that gets made to decide what
follows what is much more elaborate than
that it tends to be it's it's based on
neural networks
which are essentially taking
uh
how to best explain this
um
you've got
you can think of it roughly
as
you are seeing a set of a set of words
or characters
and you're kind of probing different
places so let's say you've got a piece
of sentence that is
50 characters long
you've got something that's think about
it like kind of a a um a creature with
lots of tentacles and different
tentacles are connected to different
letters
and what's happening is it's kind of the
the if you say letter number three is
connected to tentacle number five or
something and it's
it's kind of uh when and when it notices
when that tentacle notices that that
letter is an a
then it says it it uh produces some kind
of uh signal and if it if some other
tentacle notices some other letter is
something else it produces some other
kind of signal and you're kind of
learning how that collection of signals
put together um what that is likely to
mean should come next
and as i say the the details of how this
works are kind of complicated um and uh
in a sense very messy um it's uh they're
typically several layers many layers of
kind of this
is sensing that and then you sense from
the layer and then you sense from that
layer and then there's more elaborate
things where you have sequences of
of things where where one one thing will
produce other things and you pay
attention to what's happening uh later
on from that sequence that's produced
and so on it's really really quite
complicated and it's not something where
humans in detail understand what's going
on inside
what's been done is people have found
sort of methods
for
for grinding up the data and producing
predictions about what's going to happen
and those methods have sort of just
just empirically been found to work and
then people feed them just huge volumes
of examples
and gradually what's happening is that
that one is setting up those programs to
to sort of follow the examples as well
as they can
okay so the end result is what should
happen is you ask it a question like you
might ask it how does gpt 3 work
and
its goal is to start producing text that
represents the answer to that question
and it's going to do that based on the
things that it's seen before
now how well does it do
you know some people would say it does
fantastically well some people would say
it does terribly
somebody produced for me recently
a a training of gpt3 that's based on
things that i've written and i've said
and transcripts of these uh
live streams and so on and i have to say
that what it produced seemed to me
terrible didn't sound like me at all it
sounded like um uh the thing was sort of
aimlessly producing sentences that i
felt like other people's sentences not
my sentences so i wasn't very impressed
um but that's that's kind of the idea is
is uh sort of regurgitate what you have
seen before
and in terms of of uh uh you know asking
questions where you're likely to be able
to get an answer from it well if there
is something where out there in the
example it's learned from there was this
question this answer then it's a good
bet that it's going to be able to
respond in that way
um
okay very different question here brian
asks uh
dangers of space junk around the earth
posing a risk to commercial space hotels
and so on
well i don't know how many objects there
are exactly in orbit around the earth i
think maybe a few hundred thousand
probably now um including uh some tens
of thousands of satellites
and some number of sort of disembodied
bolts that fell out of satellites and
things like this
there is all of these things attract
it's pretty easy if you have a metal
object even quite a small one it it uh
reflects radar much better than other
things and so it's comparatively easy to
track all the stuff that's in orbit
around the earth
and
one of the things that is
certainly
an issue
for example
there have been a few incidents where
there have been few incidents where
people have tried to
sort of blow up satellites with lasers
and things like this there have been
other incidents uh where
not too many but some
where satellites have collided with each
other
in in those kinds of cases
the um
uh
it's um
uh
lots of pieces of stuff get thrown out
into orbit and you have a lot of sort of
uh
pieces of junk that are in orbit now you
know a satellite goes in in low earth
orbit at least at 20 at 17 000 miles an
hour around the earth
so if you end up with two satellites
that are in different orbits and they
cross over and they collide they are
colliding at a very high speed and so
the amount of so they'll tend to produce
lots of um uh lots of junk now what
tends to happen is that
uh something which is in orbit around
the earth will kind of stay in that same
orbit the orbit if it's low down to the
earth like let's say 50 miles up or
something like this if it's low down to
the earth the orbit will steadily decay
because what's happening is that kind of
wisps of air from the atmosphere to kind
of reach up into space and the the um uh
those will tend to collide with whatever
is orbiting and that will gradually
cause the orbiting thing to lose
its angular momentum and to lose speed
and to gradually decay into the into the
atmosphere and probably eventually burn
up in the atmosphere because it gets
because because as it as it starts to uh
to go into the thicker parts of the
atmosphere what's happening is you've
got a thing going at um i don't know 25
000 miles an hour let's say as it falls
towards the earth
and that is something which as the air
flows around it it's going to it'll get
very hot from from all of the collisions
of air molecules with that um uh with
that object and and that's why you know
when spacecraft re-enter the earth's
atmosphere they have to have these
elaborate heat shields uh usually made
of ceramics and so on that um uh that
protect them because the outside
the outside of the spacecraft is it's
it's being it's being bombarded with the
air at very high speed and that air is
kind of it's kind of it's it's the same
mechanism as friction if you rub solids
against each other they'll get hot and
it's it's the same basic mechanisms
that's happening where a very fast
object falling through something like
air also gets hot like that
so
in terms of
people certainly worry about
the increasing amount of kind of
junk that's in orbit around the earth
and you can start worrying about these
kind of streams these areas these sort
of tubes of debris if if some satellite
blew up there's there's there'll be some
place where that so when it blows up or
when something happens to it it will
there'll be things that are just going
in the direction of the orbit and then
if the thing explodes then that the the
force of the explosion will cause some
of the pieces to be not quite in the
same orbit and so you'll end up with a
sort of tube of stuff that is uh in some
range of orbits going around the earth
and the question is if you are in the
way of that that's that's bad news so to
speak
and there are uh so people
uh that the how rapidly that will build
up i'm not sure i think the thing that
people always worry about is that if a
bunch of debris builds up then it will
be the case that the chance that a given
satellite will be
destroyed by debris goes up
and
though when that satellite is destroyed
it will produce more debris and so it
essentially produces a chain reaction of
debris where more and more debris is
produced and eventually it's uh
you're kind of dodging bolts all the
time if you want to be in earth orbit
i think we're far away from that
situation right now and uh there's sort
of questions about what to do about it i
know there's at least one company i uh
ran across where they're interested in
in providing essentially uh salvage
services in orbit where they're going to
send up their own satellite that can
kind of maneuver around and try and pick
things up and so on um and there are
various initiatives like that
i mean there's also the question of can
you
uh can you zap if you know that there's
a bolt in orbit somewhere can you zap it
with a laser for example and let's say
even vaporize it um and cause it to then
not be uh not be harmful to other things
um that's that's also a possible thing
to do
you know there's a there's a question
here
um
the uh
the question here it seems like science
literacy is on the decline what can we
do about it what does it mean to be
scientifically literate
i'm not sure that science literacy is on
the decline i think there's more and
more knowing in science
and so there's more and more to learn
i mean i've noticed in the course of my
life that the general
awareness among people that there is a
thing
there are things to know in science has
definitely gone up and the importance of
knowing things in science has definitely
been something that uh
people view as being
more worthwhile i think because
more and more
is being said on the basis of science
that affects people's everyday lives
which wasn't always the case
but in terms of
what
what what sort of is scientific literacy
what does this mean what what um uh i
would say that the obviously these live
streams that i'm doing are my attempt to
uh kind of transfer whatever scientific
literacy i might have to to other people
um and i think sort of the core in a
sense of scientific literacy is probably
knowing stuff about science
knowing uh sort of facts about science
knowing what's been discovered in
science over the years
i think that um that's uh and across
lots of different kinds of science and
some kinds of science uh are very much
sort of on their own some really connect
to others i would say that getting to
the point where
when you uh getting there's a in some
areas of science there's a certain
amount of jargon that you have to know
um otherwise you just really can't
understand what people are talking about
about those areas of science
i would say one place where that gets uh
rather whether where the um uh one one
common place of interest to people is
medicine where there tends to be a fair
amount of jargon and uh as soon as you
know a decent amount of that you can
immediately understand a lot more and
without that you're kind of somewhat
locked out of that i have to say it's
one of those cases where having learnt
latin as a kid that's super useful in
medical jargon because most of it
actually some of it hasn't changed since
the time of um uh writers like galen and
in um you know in antiquity writing
about these things and in in some sense
when you hear one of these pieces of
medical job and you don't understand it
if you remember words in latin you just
translate from um the jargon is just a
piece of latin and you can translate it
um but so you know learning
the kind of the facts and jargon the
basic facts and jargon of different
fields is is really worthwhile
um i'm not sure uh it um
uh i think then
a certain degree
of
mathematical literacy is useful
because it's like oh there's this
percentage of that and there's this
chance of this happening and then if
there's a chance of this and then
there's another given that there's a
chance of this how do you combine
probabilities those kinds of things um
those are those are worthwhile
and i would say that the uh the things
that perhaps
some of the things that are worth
knowing in science are things that are
really quite unobvious
from everyday experience i mean the
famous one from 500 years ago was the
fact that the earth goes round the sun
not the other way around
um and that was something that from our
everyday experience
that's just hanging out on the earth and
seeing the sun you know travel through
the sky and so on that's not obvious
that that's the right way to think about
things but that's something that kind of
was delivered by science by copernicus
and and and others um 500 years ago and
it's something where not obvious but
that's something that science can tell
us
and
that it's something we have to kind of
know from science and so there are a
bunch of things like that that are sort
of not obvious to us there are things
about
the universe in the large things in the
small
there are things about mathematics
there are things that are sort of
surprising about the way that let's say
probabilities combine and so on that you
kind of have to learn as a matter of
learning science
in a sense in the course of our
civilization uh it has been it's taken
centuries often to learn these things
and there are things those are not
things that you can immediately uh
absorb from your everyday experience
just as other people weren't able to
absorb them and it took centuries for
scientists to discover them so it's
worth kind of giving yourself the the uh
the the sort of leapfrogging of those
centuries by by just learning what's
what's already known
i think the uh when when you get to the
sort of more advanced levels of this
having kind of computational literacy
and being able to you know use like our
computational language to just say hey
i've i've seen that there's this data on
this thing i wonder what's actually true
about that and to be able to actually
with your own sort of fingers figure out
what's going on that's i think when you
really get to a a high level of kind of
scientific literacy is when you can go
from whatever the raw data about
something was to making your own
conclusions but that's a that's a fairly
high level of of scientific literacy
i would say the other thing that i
notice is almost uh in addition to
literacy this kind of scientific
judgment
what is likely to be true what is likely
to be even known whether it is true or
not
um these are things where
you
people i think often get quite confused
about what might be knowable what might
not be knowable they'll see some
headline that says you know scientists
say blah blah blah
and to somebody who kind of knows
science and has reasonable science
judgment you'd immediately you're
rolling your eyes and saying no
scientists can't possibly know that that
headline has to be nonsense and you know
it's it's maybe it's an overclaimed
headline or maybe it's a
confusion of some kind
but
you know it's it's a question of of what
getting a sense of what is knowable and
what is not
uh and what kinds of things might we
have
uh data knowledge about in the world and
what might we not
for some reason i'm i'm reminded of a of
a question which was right on the edge
um
that one of my kids asked a long time
ago which is um when there were
dinosaurs could the earth have had two
moons
and i realized that i didn't know
and i know enough about
how one works out things about the
dynamics of planets and so on that i
knew that for maybe 10 million years in
the past and 10 million years in the
future you can kind of do mathematical
calculations to trace the orbits of
planets
um and you can know that nothing too
funky happened in the solar system over
that period of time but if you ask me
for 65 million years i i knew that i
didn't know that um
the the question is is is it knowable
could somebody actually have worked that
out i i wasn't sure
and in that particular case i asked over
a period of quite a few years i asked
all kinds of different people who are
experts in in celestial mechanics and
and other kinds of things and i think
the general conclusion was
uh when i began asking it it was like we
just don't know and later on it became
well now we've been able to do computer
simulations of the solar system for
longer and really it's it's it's quite
implausible that the earth had two moons
65 million years ago but if you ask
about two billion years ago we just
don't know
um and this is something where
uh that's sort of that's an example of
something that's very much on the edge
now if you say you know if you pick all
kinds of weird claims i don't know let's
let's pick a claim
let's say
um
let's have a claim
really
the um uh the whales
have a giant civilization at the bottom
of the pacific ocean
and uh we just have never found out
about it because they didn't want us to
know about it is this a plausible claim
or not
how could we figure out whether
something like that
is even conceivable or whether it's just
uh
uh totally bogus so to speak well so
first thing we have to know for example
one question would be have we mapped the
whole ocean floor have we have we
visited the whole ocean floor
well mapping the ocean floor is not so
difficult because we have uh uh we can
use sonar for example to we we produce
some sound and water goes through the
water it bounces off the ocean floor
comes back up we measure the amount of
time it takes we can make
we can figure out things about the depth
of the oceans
we can also do that
more directly even in in shallower
oceans people did that from you know
from a long time ago if you literally
just have a
a cable and you let the cable out and
you you wait until it hits the bottom of
the ocean and you see how far that is
um
and so the question of you know have we
have we mapped the bottom of the oceans
everywhere yes the answer is yes there
are good maps
of uh sort of the terrain at the bottom
of the ocean have we been there
uh not to most places
it's it's difficult to get uh you have
to that the technology exists but people
have been to the lowest points in the
ocean the marianas trench um but it's a
rare thing to do and it's not something
commonly done
um so uh and you know if we start asking
questions about um well you know it's an
interesting one to try and uh uh
sort of unpack is how would we know um
and for example
uh sort of related to questions about um
uh you know how do we know
whether
uh take i don't know dolphins whales
whatever you know they they they have
all kinds of sounds that they make
um you know what are those sounds are
those the recitals of poetry are they
just uh
kind of are they like
like birds songs just uh being produced
uh
uh apparently uh just to show that
they're there kind of thing uh what are
they and how can one tell well those are
actually pretty difficult questions and
i don't think if somebody said
actually
you know the whales have developed epic
poetry and they're reciting it
across the pacific ocean so to speak the
sound travels a long way in the pacific
ocean i'm not sure that it's easy to
refute that claim
um it's uh
but i mean let's see what what will be
some other things that um
uh people might claim
that um oh i don't know
um
they're questions like um
uh what would be a good example um
[Music]
hmm that's a good example but let me say
that areas where there's
see they're different kinds of
scientific knowledge that have different
degrees of certainty so for example
let's say
in mathematics
you say
the following relation is true 3 squared
plus 4 squared equals 5 squared
okay
well immediately you might not know if
it's true or not but you can clearly
work that out and you can determine
definitively yes it is true
and that's a case where there is a very
high degree of certainty
now if i say to you
uh for example
every
even number
is the sum of two primes
okay
you can say well you know let's take the
number eight
it's equal to uh five plus three okay
great that's 8 is the sum of two primes
let's take 20 we can work out what it is
it's um you know 17 plus 3 it's again
the sum of two primes and we keep doing
that
and we keep um
uh checking you know is every number the
sum of two primes
we'll
we'll
we'll discover in that particular case
that um yes we can keep checking we can
keep checking for trillions of numbers
and it always seems to be true that
every even number is the sum of two
primes do we know if it's really really
true well that's been a thing called go
backs conjecture and it's been an open
question for about 300 years whether
that's true or not people are getting
closer and closer to finding a precise
kind of logical proof
that
that is always true but we don't know
for sure yet and it's still possible
that there's an even number out there
that isn't the sum of two primes so
that's a sort of there's a there's a
high degree of certainty but it isn't
absolutely slam dunk certain i mean
there's an example of something a bit
like that you can estimate actually the
density of prime numbers
and the so-called prime number theorem
tells one that roughly the the
the density of prime numbers goes down
roughly like the logarithm of the size
of the number so as you prime numbers
remember numbers that you can't
represent as uh products of other
numbers so for example just like you can
say i don't know 10 is 5 times 2 it's
not a prime number 11 the only thing you
can say is 11 is 11 times 1 there's no
way to break it up into two numbers that
you can multiply together that will get
11. and so you go through and look at
different numbers you'll find that there
are lots of prime numbers and the
density of prime numbers the chance the
number is prime gradually goes down as
the numbers get bigger that's sort of
not surprising it's kind of like well
there are more ways you might be able to
make up the number from smaller numbers
as the number gets bigger and we know
you know one thing that was proved by
euclid actually in antiquity is that
they're an infinite number of primes
uh we don't know for example another
thing you know talking of certainty are
twin primes primes like 11 and 13 which
differ just by two
um there we found lots and lots of twin
primes but it's still not known even
after two thousand years if they're an
infinite number of twin primes we know
they're an infinite number of primes
altogether we just don't know whether
they can always whether there will be uh
where the forever will keep on getting
infinite uh twin primes
so
it um it could be the case that the
density of primes becomes so low that
there are no longer twin primes anymore
um but it seems unlikely but um it's not
a proved fact at this point
by the way even when we talk about
things where we say it's proved it's
established it's mathematically
established well in in setting up
mathematics we always have to start from
certain kinds of axioms we have to start
from things like we say you know it's
always true about addition that a plus b
is equal to b plus a that addition is
commutative it's always true that this
or that um it's always true that if you
can prove something about n
from the thing about n minus one you can
keep doing that that's the idea of
induction that if you can prove
something from a thing about the case of
n from the case of n minus one and you
can prove for the case of one then you
can prove it for all n um there's
there's a collection of axioms that you
provide that is the sort of raw material
from which you build up your
mathematical uh ideas but then one of
the things we know from gurdel's theorem
from 1931
is that there are things which you can
write down
that
seem like that's their questions about
let's say arithmetic like other an
infinite number of twin primes is go
back's conjecture about um about prime's
true and so on but which
the axioms of arithmetic
as we know them as we write them down
and not powerful enough to prove
so those things uh might
that there's there's no way just from
the things that we have defined to be
the way that we set up our mathematics
to establish those facts so that that's
a bit about sort of certainty in in
mathematics you know what's uh uh there
are many things where you can
definitively say
yes
this is you know i can calculate it it's
true or given the axioms that i'm
assuming for my mathematics i can prove
by logic that this is true so i'm done
there
so now the question is well what about
natural science what about things about
the world
well it gets much more complicated
because we don't have an intrinsic way
to know how the world works
the world works according to natural
laws
in physics for example we are pretty
confident that if we make a carefully
out of design physics experiment
and that we do the experiment once we do
it again we'll get the same answer every
time in some sense
there are many footnotes to that issue
having to do with quantum mechanics for
example um where we only can
apparently work out
in fact a lot of this gets very much
informed by our
recent work on fundamental theory of
physics um i think we can we can now
understand why it is
that there is sort of uh
uncertainty in the results of
experiments that we do in physics and it
really has to do with us as observers
sampling this kind of infinite thing
which we call the ruliad which is this
kind of this infinite entangled
collection of all possible computational
processes in a sense all possible
histories of the universe and the
question is which of these do we sample
and the answer is the partic there are
particular ones that we're sampling by
virtue of the way that we we experience
and our senses experience the universe
uh the particular and and it is that
sampling of this ultimately completely
determined collection of all possible
histories it's our sampling of that that
determines what we actually perceive in
physics
and so that's um uh so so there's sort
of the in a sense the um uh the
uncertainty about what happens has to do
with well how are we looking at it more
than in some sense what's ultimately
really there
um but it doesn't do us any good to say
well in principle there's this really ad
thing that is the sort of the the set of
all possible physics is and so on that
doesn't really do us any good because
what we care about is what we experience
in the actual physical world with our
methods of perception and that's the
specific laws of physics that we have
but so in physics
there's you know when people say well
such and such a thing has been
discovered et cetera et cetera et cetera
uh there's
there's a certain degree of solidity to
that but it's very tricky because you
know when somebody says we've done an
experiment it was a really hard
experiment we got the following very
unexpected result is it right is it not
right
you know for instance
in um for a while people said this was
in the um
70s i guess 1970s people were worried
that the sun might have gone out
that the sun might have stopped
that the center of the sun
might have might no longer be producing
energy
okay why'd they say that
well and i'm sure there are a bunch of
uh sort of trashy newspaper headlines
along those lines
the um
uh
the center of the sun is like 10 million
degrees centigrade
it's um
and when you produce light
photon heat the center of the sun it
takes like a million years for the thing
to get to the surface of the sun
and um because it keeps on the sun is
not transparent and it's it's like that
piece of heat keeps on getting from one
uh
it takes it a long time to kind of
diffuse through the layers of the sun
but
that's not true for neutrinos neutrinos
are particles that interact very little
so it's very typical for a neutrino to
go all the way through the earth without
interacting
and in the the nuclear reactions that
happen in the sun produce neutrinos and
so one of the things people expected is
from the center of the sun there will be
all kinds of neutrinos being produced
that would get to the earth and if we
were clever enough we could detect those
neutrinos on the earth and we could even
sort of in a sense x-ray what's
happening neutrino ray what's happening
at the center of the sun
um but in fact
no neutrinos were observed uh coming
from the sun and it's like oh my gosh
you know what's going on and so there
were all kinds of theories about the
reactions at the center of the sun and
there was maybe the sun has gone out
that would be very bad eventually i mean
it would take millions of years probably
for the badness to sort of diffuse out
but but um uh or maybe there was
something wrong with the experiment as
it turned out there was something wrong
with the experiment um it was a
difficult experiment where you're kind
of looking for
flashes of light in these giant tanks of
fluid that are in mines deep under the
earth etc etc etc and you have to kind
of calculate if a neutrino goes through
in this way how would the flashes of
light be produced and it wasn't quite
done correctly um and there wasn't
really a test where you could say well
we know that this produces neutrinos in
this way
and so we can test whether we kind of
know the apparatus is working properly
and so on that's a place where
where you know even the finest physics
experiment just got the wrong answer
and concluded something something
strange
now
you know there are other
things that people like for example when
people first discovered that the
universe was expanding back in the
1920s i guess
that was a very surprising claim
it turns out those experiments were not
terribly hard to do
and it was pretty easy to determine that
yes that really was correct now in more
recent times people say the universe is
expanding a bit more quickly than you
would expect and that's leading to all
kinds of theories of dark energy and
negative mass matter and all kinds of
things like this
is that correct is it not correct it's a
tricky issue it's a tricky issue having
to do with looking at you know
supernovas exploding stars having to
figure out things like is a supernova
that exploded in the first billion years
of the universe does it produce the same
amount of energy as a supernova that
explodes today
you know how does one how does one
confirm that it's very hard to confirm
so you have to have these kind of nets
of theories that say whether uh how you
interpret these experiments and so on so
it again gets gets quite tricky to know
whether the experiments are right or not
and you know there are there are things
where there have been in the history of
physics that i've known it there have
been several kinds of things where
people regularly every decade or so
they'll say we found this effect we
found this particular thing
and
and turns out
it isn't correct one of the things that
i've sometimes used as a heuristic
is when somebody says i found this
effect and nobody ever imagined that it
could be there
i give it an uptick in my in in whether
i think it's likely to be true
because in a sense if you see something
that nobody ever thought was going to be
there it's like it's not like you are
you are setting up your whole
experimental analysis and so on on the
basis of this is what we're going to see
now we confirm it but anyway even in
physics it's often hard to know and and
one slowly gets an intuition for what
kinds of things are like that's a slam
dunk it's it's easy to tell that that
experiment will be correct uh i don't
know when the higgs particle was
discovered for example in particle
accelerators and in collisions of high
energy protons and antiprotons um the uh
uh you could look at the data uh where
you know where there was some thing of a
certain mass that was produced you could
look at the data and uh i don't know
somebody like me who's probably seen a
lot of this kind of stuff before could
pretty much say yeah it's probably right
you know that that's a sufficiently
clean signal that's probably correct
there are other cases where sort of
things are seen where you look at it and
you're like the data is wiggling around
all over the place you know is it really
going up is it really going down is
there really a bump there very hard to
tell and um you kind of know you know if
somebody is claiming something big on
the basis of this data it's kind of like
well maybe probably not
if you go outside the physics
things get much more difficult
because for example in biology one of
the issues is that sort of every
organism is different all of us people
are a bit different so and even you know
different days will behave differently
and you know
if we say
you know this particular drug has this
particular effect on us so this
particular
you know vaccine has this particular
effect on us
well it's going to depend on the person
because we all have slightly different
uh genetics we have slightly different
we've you know we've grown in slightly
different ways we've eaten different
things we've had different experiences
and so on so no two are the same and so
it's it's much harder to do kind of a
controlled experiment where you can say
this is what's true you know everybody
who has who eats this is going to have
this happen
well it's it's not the case it's there's
a there's a distribution of outcomes
depending on the person and and it can
be very confusing because it's like
somebody will say this thing has some
terrible this thing has some wonderful
effect
okay it's a wonderful effect but only on
10 of people
and but if you know what is a special
about those 10 percent of people then
maybe on those people
90 of the people who you can identify as
having that special feature it'll have a
wonderful effect and so on but it's kind
of like first thing is when you hear
some kind of claim about uh you know all
this do that in biology it you have to
kind of read the fine print um it's also
the case that people will do
sometimes oh i don't know they'll
they'll say um
what's a good example
uh
there's all sorts of shocking examples
but okay here's one i i don't know i
haven't seen a particular study on this
but i i'm i'm sufficiently certain
here's an example example would be
um
people in certain western countries have
higher iqs than people in other
countries
a claim somebody might make
okay well let's unpack that claim
what do you mean by iq very dubious
concept to begin with but you probably
mean somebody did
you know an iq test
okay
well you know people in this country
have probably been to school and they've
seen all kinds of tests that are just
like that people in some other country
their school works differently they you
know they don't go to school the same
ways
they've seen different kinds of things
but the conclusion you know the original
stated thing was you know people in you
know country x western country x
you know have higher iq than people in
whatever okay
that claim is
is
no doubt bogus
and but the reason it gets that way is
because the people you know people are
better at doing tests that they've seen
examples of before people are and so if
you it's sort of a self-fulfilling
prophecy because if you say well we're
gonna test the things that people have
learned in this system of education then
it's kind of unsurprising
that uh that they will do better in
those tests
now can you roll that back to make the
conclusion
they have a higher iq whatever iq might
mean
well of course if your definition of iq
is they do better on this kind of test
then the answer might be yes they do
better on that kind of test but you
might from the headline you might say oh
that means that their brains work better
in some way
undoubtedly not true
and the you know so that's that's the
kind of thing where it's like
sort of i would say the scientific
judgment is you know what does this
claim mean could it possibly you know is
there some trivial reason why it might
be true
what what what kind of measurement could
possibly have even been done
to establish it and so on um so i think
those are those are kinds of things that
are are useful in sort of testing one's
one's scientific judgment is you know
you see these headlines and you ask the
question you know could this possibly be
true does this does this mean what it
says it means does it mean what the
person who wrote it thinks it means even
does it um and it is
uh you know i i think that that
sometimes science is just hard and
people uh get the wrong answers
sometimes uh the science is is terrific
but people will then take
that
that sort of scientific claim and
through misunderstanding or
trying to achieve some particular
purpose will turn that into oh there's
some you know dramatic conclusion that
can be made um on the basis of that and
look it's backed up by the science over
here i'm sometimes shocked at some of
the things that that i've invented in
science where i see you know people
saying oh this means that
and it's like like a a pretty common one
is some things about um the universe is
a computer and we must live in a
simulation which is completely
not the conclusion or even the correct
way of thinking about a lot of the
science that i've done but that's
something where people have kind of a
very common trend a very common trait is
people will take something about science
that may be a little hard to understand
and they'll kind of drag it into
something which is as close as possible
to terms that they understand and
sometimes it it breaks it to do that
sometimes the science a bit more subtle
and it doesn't just fit into the the
kind of the rubric the framework that
one knows for example from everyday
experience
so that that's another kind of
phenomenon you know i would say that um
one of the things about sort of
scientific literacy and and getting it
so to speak is this concept that
people i hope
uh you know i hope some of what i try to
do in these live streams supports that
is like you can actually figure stuff
out you can actually think about things
it's not the case that all science for
example is just delivered by scientists
and you don't get to uh and it's just a
pure a sort of um thing that arises as
kind of a a a sort of a a a a
kind of a text that's just delivered in
its final form and this is true and
that's all there is to it
it's
if it is the case that you know
something is presented scientifically
you should be able to unpack it think
through it know why it's true know
even if you don't well in some cases
you know if you ask some question about
physics
why is energy conserved in physics well
i think i i am beginning to know the
answer to that on the basis of our
fundamental theory of physics but that's
not
something that people have been able to
have to answer that question why before
but there are many things that sort of
not at that foundational of a level in
science where you can absolutely say you
know why does this work this way why is
that the case that oh i don't know in
some
uh biology medicine
uh
engineering type thing you know why is
it
that um
uh that this thing happens you should be
able to explain that in terms of sort of
more general principles so i think
another thing to say about sort of
explanations in science
is you've got a particular phenomenon i
don't know
um
uh clouds are white
let's say
so you could explain that phenomenon
just the what does it mean to explain
that phenomenon what it means is you are
sort of going down to a lower level and
you're saying well clouds are made of
water vapor water vapor has these
characteristics light has these
characteristics going through water
vapor you're going to a higher level of
generality in the explanation so in
other words there are clouds are one
thing that's made of water vapor but
water vapor occurs in other places and
other gases occur in other places so
you're going from the particular of wire
clouds white to more general principles
and the the essence of scientific
explanation is to go from the most
general principles you can to the
explaining the particulars of what
you're dealing with at that particular
moment or in that particular question so
i think that's a and sometimes when you
get to those general principles you
eventually reach the point where you say
we don't know we don't know why energy
is conserved we just know that it is
conserved we don't know why this or that
thing is true about physics i have to
say in physics we're beginning to i
think have a lot of good explanations
for those things in terms of uh sort of
ultimately in terms of formal
mathematical kinds of deductions that
are things which we can say must be true
they're not things that are well
those things must be true the particular
ways that we sample and observe those
things that's a slightly trickier issue
to understand that has to do with the
the particulars of how we uh you know we
perceive things and uh and so on
but so i think in some sense when you
say is there a scientific explanation of
this what you mean is can you go from
the particular phenomenon down to
something which is based on more general
principles so if you take examples in
biology medicine you know why is it
that
this i don't know
uh disease works this way or this
medical phenomenon works this way
to just say well it works that way
because it works that way it's not
really good enough to be able to say
well
it is that way because of some feature
of molecular biology and something about
you know proteins of this type have this
kind of property and and this and that
and the other by going to those more
general principles that's what it really
means to have a scientific explanation
and i think that sort of in some sense
as scientific literacy perhaps can be
thought about in terms of do you know
those principles do you know those
underlying principles and to what extent
can you successfully reason
about things and sort of bring them down
to the level of those principles
and again it's uh and sort of a good
test case i suppose are these things
about you know is this science headline
you know plausible is it is it even
knowable
is it um uh
uh you know is is it something where
where we could in the current state you
know if somebody says some uh
you know a um
an ad for a breakfast cereal
has been spotted
on uh
you know
um on a planet orbiting another star
very implausible claim
but
that claim one could know
is not a claim that is that you know
that that claim couldn't possibly be
true in the current state of our
knowledge telescopes just do not exist
that have the resolution to be able to
you know read the ad so to speak um on
you know a planet or orbiting another
star um it's uh um now could you build
such a telescope interesting question or
you know could somebody say in a hundred
years could we do that
well that then you have to know some
more things and you have to know about
uh sort of the criteria you know what
limits the resolution of telescopes
while on the surface of the earth it's
limited by the atmosphere to large
extent but ultimately it's limited by
the size of the telescope compared to
the wavelength of light and so on and so
you can imagine you build a big enough
telescope you can in principle see uh
very
arbitrarily high resolutions but it
becomes more and more challenging to
build that bigger intel bigger telescope
but i think
i mean in in yeah i was going to say
that that one of the things that i think
is sort of a big enemy of science
literacy is kind of
a sort of science as delivered fact so
to speak
where where it's just like everything
about science is just like learn this
fact learn this fact learn this fact now
knowing facts is super useful but but
believing that there is no way to unpack
those facts as a mistake
and you know i think it's as i say it's
it's a good thing to to sort of wonder
about this or that question about
science and just say do i know
principles which would allow me to to
make conclusions about that another
thing that can happen it's happened a
lot in in these uh pandemic times for
example is people quote numbers
and they say oh they've been this number
of cases and this number of
fate hospitalizations and this number of
of
of this is and that's
and and one of the challenges is to
unpack what those numbers really mean so
for example somebody might say there
have been a lot more cases in the u.s
than there have been in australia
okay it's like oh my gosh you know
something the us must have done
something bad or something well of
course the first thing to realize is
that the population of the us is about
350 million or something population of
australia is what i don't know 20 25
million or something like that
so it's um there's a you know the the to
say that there are more cases in the us
than in australia is like well you know
what is probably the more interesting
question is number of cases divided by
population what is the chance that any
given person would get sick for example
so that's the beginning but then you can
ask questions you know when when you see
these numbers kind of all packed up
into
oh you know
this number is uh the fraction of people
who have this at that and so on
it's it's always a kind of a challenge
to see if you can unpack those numbers
and see what did those numbers really
mean now sometimes numbers are only
quoted in in
in some kind of combined form and you
actually can't deduce the thing that
would be the really interesting thing to
know because people have uh
have quoted those numbers in a certain
way
um
the um
uh
um
so
it's some
uh
so anyway the the the um
uh that that's sort of another piece to
this whole kind of scientific literacy
thing is is understanding how to unpack
these numbers and and very often
really all it is is dividing numbers by
other numbers and and knowing you know a
percentage increase
uh you know what that means just
sometimes it's more a question of uh
if if
x percent of these people do this and
why percent of those x percent do this
what does that mean do the combined
thing and so on and and then it gets a
little bit trickier and sometimes you
have to know rules for combining
probabilities and things like that and
there are some slightly tricky
mathematical uh results about combining
probabilities that often get kind of
confusing
well okay so that was a little bit on um
uh
on scientific literacy i think i think
as i say my my
my main statement would be
there's a lot that
sort of
if you know a certain set of scientific
facts there's a lot that you can kind of
unpack and figure out for yourself
and just to read the headline and say oh
scientists have said x
it's like
there's there's subtext below those
headlines in in all fields
and um uh you know
the kind of the the way to
to really be scientifically literate is
to be able to get down to say could that
be true why is it true what does it mean
that it's true and so on rather than
just like oh another fact you know it's
um and there are things where sometimes
i remember
when people first claimed that the
dinosaurs were killed by an asteroid
impact um
that
there were things about that that might
at first have seen completely
implausible but as you dug a little bit
you realize that well actually
you know like there's this time there's
a thin layer of iridium iridium i think
um sort of ash
that coats the earth at a certain depth
that corresponds to the um the the you
know the vaporized um uh asteroid that
that hit the earth 65 million years ago
and
you know when that's observed in
different places around the earth and so
on that becomes somewhat convincing that
that really did happen that way but it
seemed very implausible at first
um but it's one of these things where
you know is it plausible is it not
plausible you dig a little bit
you you kind of start seeing whether
it's plausible or not sometimes also
there are
uh you know one of the things that can
happen is there's a theory it says a
definite thing oh the theory didn't
quite work right so people patch the
theory and they say well there's also
this effect and oh the others also this
effect and of course it happens this way
because there's also this extra thing
when it gets more and more shaggy dog
like that uh it it again the sort of
scientific judgment says it's less and
less likely to be right
but that's not always true like for
example the current theory of the
formation of the moon
is this big splat theory involves like
well one thing had to hit the earth and
two things had to coalesce and then that
produced this whole uh bunch of stuff
that then
it's kind of like two steps to produce
the moon whereas you might have thought
that the most plausible theory would be
a one-step theory but that's a case
where it seems like maybe the two-step
thing is right but if if you said it was
an 18-step process um to produce the
moon um
the uh um
uh
you know then that um
um
that um
uh that that seems much less plausible
so anyway
um
let's see
well the question here about um
uh
dr verm
do you think the scientific process has
been damaged during the pandemic
but more because the speed of
information opinion on the internet look
i think
i think the pandemic has not been a
great moment
in the history of uh sort of uh
of credibility for science
um in my opinion
the worst problem has been a sort of
failure to communicate what science
knows and what science doesn't know and
a great tendency to just sort of
announce
science implies this science implies
that
when realistically if you know the
science it is not as definitive as that
now it's a challenging thing because
it's a question of you know what do you
do
with uh you know people who have a range
of different levels of uh you know
panicking about things and ignoring
things and and so on what do you do how
do you best communicate
uh sort of what's known and what's not
my own tendency which perhaps is perhaps
is more you know suitable for for me
than for everybody is just say what you
know and say what you don't know
and that way kind of we're all in it
together so to speak rather than just
sort of announcing this is what's true
or or people saying no no it's all
nonsense
um that if you can accurately convey
what's known and what's not known
and and and why you know go a little bit
down to the level of principles for
people who care um you know if you if
you say this is what's known and and you
know i think a larger number of people
than one might imagine you know i
certainly know many people who i would
not have expected to be following kind
of the scientific details of the
pandemic have been following it in much
more detail than one might one might
have imagined and i think that to have
provided sort of more levels of well ex
well explained science
below kind of just this is true got to
do this et cetera et cetera et cetera
would have been a good thing
i mean i think that um there's a
uh
it's a question of of uh you know how
worried should one be about this well
sometimes it's like we don't really know
you know what's going to happen well we
don't really know but here's what we do
know
and i think that
in in many cases for people to have been
able to come up with to some extent i
mean i think that there are for example
people's assessment of risks of
different kinds of things for themselves
and for other people sometimes people
sometimes people are completely crazy
about that they have completely wrong
estimates of risk for themselves and for
other people but sometimes they know
plenty about their local environment and
they are better able to assess risks
than than one is from the outside so to
speak but i i think that um now in terms
of sort of scientific communication you
know on the internet and so on uh
you know there's clearly crazy stuff
that's happened but there's also good
stuff that's happened there's a lot of
things where it's been sort of a
question of collaboratively figuring out
what's true and the fact that people you
know send out a tweet and somebody else
responds to that and so on and it all
happens in a few hours is a really good
thing and uh you know sometimes you know
something completely crazy is said and
then something else crazy has said and
all spirals out of control but there's
also been lots of good stuff that's been
done by virtue of of kind of very uh
kind of
you know people who don't know each
other at all who are just sort of
anonymous handles on the internet
exchanging good sort of scientific
thinking and and coming up with good
conclusions i think that
you know people have had the idea
that oh you know there's a gold standard
in science there's a way science knows
intrinsically whether things are true or
not and sometimes people talk about you
know peer review of journals and things
like this but you know there really
isn't a gold standard of what's true in
science there are things that get you
you know more more levels of certainty
more levels of it's not complete
nonsense and so on but it isn't the case
that there's a you know it's a nice
solution typically had by people outside
of science that things like you know the
peer review process is going to
determine if it's true or not well it
doesn't it's a it's a very imperfect
process like everything you know i have
to say for myself it's kind of like you
see one of these headlines whatever it
is and it's like okay
uh you know do i believe that
i'm going to have my own opinion about
whether it's true or not
and sometimes
actually quite often in this pandemic
i've said let me go and look at the raw
data okay i'm able to do that you know i
can fire up my organ language on my
computer and and
start ingesting data and actually make
the plots and see what happens and so on
and it's like sometimes i'm like rolling
my eyes and it's like whatever you know
why are people claiming this this is
obviously nonsense based on this data i
have to say i've i've tended to avoid
saying too much about it because it's
like i haven't you know if you say did i
get it right or not i'm pretty sure i
got it right i got it right enough that
i'm prepared to make decisions for
myself on that basis
did i get it right enough that you know
i know that i've nailed every single
possible effect and i know every
possible footnote about what's going on
well i haven't done that amount of work
so you know that that means i'm not
going to go and put up a big flag and
say i'm absolutely certain about this
because i haven't done all the work to
tell that i'm certain enough that i'm
prepared to make decisions on the basis
of what i figured out for myself at
least i mean also realistically
unfortunately the level of kind of
politicization and unpleasantness
associated with kind of sort of uh
science around this pandemic has been so
high that for people like me it's a it's
a major disincentive to actually sort of
say very much at all uh publicly about
things because it's like oh my gosh you
know somebody is going to think i'm
saying this and that and the other and
you know that's going to be a huge
disaster and that's not my not my cause
you know i'm i'm just uh i might be
interested in what's true i don't think
i have a particular agenda
in you know this is true versus that's
true and so on but people are going to
based on what i might conclude is true
people are going to say oh you must be
saying that because blah blah blah blah
blah
you know it's an interesting challenge i
i will say something uh sort of a
personal piece of this is that some of
what we've done in our physics project
has provided a kind of formalism and
approach
that um
has um
uh
uh that seems to have a bunch of
interesting things to say about
immunology
and i have been kind of nervous about um
uh investigating that because it's like
you know i don't know how much we'll be
able to figure out but we may very well
be able to figure out things that that
conclude things about things that are
actually relevant for decision making in
the world
and i'm i'm you know i really don't know
how those chips are going to fall you
know i haven't done the science i don't
know what the science is going to say
and you know it's uh there are things
where i'd say oh that's great you know
it's good for the world it's it's a it's
a good thing and there are things where
i'd say hmm well i wish it hadn't come
out that way but that's where the
science led
and i'm but i'm a little i'm concerned
because i think that uh you know it's
if things come out in particular ways
it's like people say oh no no no you you
you cooked it to come out that way
because you have some whole belief
system that's based on that which i
don't think i do um and so i it's kind
of a bit of a challenge to see how you
do that science and most likely what
i'll end up doing is kind of describing
to people every step and what's
happening so you know if the chips are
falling one way what may very well
happen it's very common in science
research is the chips seem to be falling
this way for a while and then you
realize no no there's this other force
that's pushing them that way and as you
kind of see these things kind of move
around in the process of doing research
you kind of realize that the chips are
just going to fall where the chips are
going to fall and it's not something
where you're kind of blowing them one
way or the other based on some
particular
sort of agenda that you might have but
that's a that's a hard thing in in
modern times
that's a hard thing to kind of convince
people of um and i think that's a that's
a disappointing feature of what's
happened but i would say that to me the
most disappointing feature is the the
lack of effort to make an exposition of
what's going on
and
and the extent to which in a sense it's
felt like uh kind of people are saying
oh no the public out there they're just
too clueless to understand we're just
going to have to tell them the
conclusion um
and uh it's um uh and sometimes tell
them conclusions that are frankly from a
science point of view uh kind of wacky
and and things where you'd say well you
know if you convince people of that well
you'll probably get them to do this or
that thing this or that thing might be
good for the world um but you know is
that really the right thing to do to
convince people of something that is in
fact not really right
in order to get them to do the thing
that might be the right thing to do
or is it better to try and tell people
the right stuff the correct you know
science or whatever
even though that might lead them to
conclude oh no i shouldn't do this thing
that uh that would be good for the world
i think that's a that's a sort of ethics
question that i have my own opinions
about i mean i i i have to say i won't i
won't i don't think i
you know i think it's better to tell
people what one what's known and let
them make up their own mind than to try
and kind of nudge them by telling by not
telling them what's known and and sort
of try and sort of manipulate them into
doing this or that thing but i also
recognize that when you run countries
and things like this that's a very
difficult it's a it's a very difficult
thing to do and there are you know it's
a the tools you have are typically very
blunt
and so the fact that you you know that
that becomes a possible tool to use
is something that i recognize might be a
you know if you're in the business of
running countries might be something
that uh
you feel is necessary so to speak um you
know i think it's unfortunate but that's
uh uh but i'm not in the um i'm not in
the business of doing things like
running countries
all right let's see
um maybe one more
um
the question here from uh
smalls
i can never read these handles i can't
even break them into into phonemes
uh let's say smoke here um
why is the development of nanotechnology
so slow to fight despite its
effectiveness in medicine oncology and
so on well so first of all what is
nanotechnology
so it's been through a bunch of
different sort of
definitions but essentially it's it's
making machines out of molecules
you know we
we
usually our devices computers all these
other kinds of things
they are
they're pretty big compared to ordinary
molecules we have a uh you know in a
in a typical computer we'll be using 100
000 electrons to encode one bit of
information our you know our whole
circuitry for our cpu chip might be you
know a centimeter across or something
and it's got these billions of
transistors and
they're getting down to the scale of of
limited numbers of atoms you know
millions of atoms perhaps
but
it's it's still it's not like we are we
are at the level where uh individual
pieces of individual molecules are sort
of doing technological kinds of things
for us and nanotechnology is kind of
about the story of making machines out
of molecules
now there is one shiny example
in the world of where essentially
machines are made out of molecules and
that's in biological systems
um and there are you know you can think
of um
a lot of things i don't know the
ribosome that
that transcribes you know uh dna it's
like this kind of machine that's making
proteins and things and it's just a
molecule that exists in all of our cells
and it's something where
biology has shown us that it's sort of
possible to make machines in some sense
out of molecules but we don't have the
ability
to to sort of make to order you know
make a cad drawing make a computer
design drawing of oh i want this machine
that's going to work this way now make a
molecule that does that
in some sense that's the mission of
chemistry but chemistry tends to work a
different way chemistry tends to be to
say these molecules will react in these
ways and it's not really a thing where
there are
there may be many steps in a chemical in
some synthesis of some chemical but it's
something it's not something where you
say there's a there's a molecule that
acts like a machine and has lots of
levers and cogs and things in it it's
more like this molecule attaches to this
and this atom is pulled away from that
and binds to this and so on it feels
like a much simpler thing
so people
tried um in the 1980s particularly there
was a big piece of enthusiasm
for sort of the the take what we can do
in machines at a large scale and make it
really really small and make that happen
at level molecules and they're lots of
questions about oh if you have a
molecule sized gear
what does that do i in fact it turns out
some bacteria have essentially uh
molecule-sized gears the little flagella
that are the little tails that that
propel the um the bacteria around that
sort of uh they have to they have to
twiddle their tails and their mechanism
for twiddling their tails looks an awful
lot like a kind of cogged gear type
assembly and it's just made of molecules
um but that's something that isn't uh
it's not something that we've uh you
know it's something not not under our
construction
and so so the the um
the traditional view has been that
nanotechnology is about taking things
that we know kind of work on a large
scale and making them very small biology
didn't really do it that way biology has
just made stuff that works
in many cases we are surprised when we
discover the things that happen in
biology and i think there's a lot we
don't know about how biology sort of
fundamentally works my own feeling is
that
the that is a much better strategy and
this is something that's come out of a
bunch of science that i've done it's a
much better strategy to take the raw
material that exists in molecules and
see how to assemble those pieces to make
things that are useful than to go and
say i know how to make a thing that's
useful and now let me sort of compile
that down to make it in terms of
molecules
um and in fact well one of the things
that's come out of our physics project
recently is kind of a new idea about how
to do things like computation at the
level of molecules typically people have
been thinking about doing computation in
the solid state where all the molecules
where everything is a solid like a the
cpu chip of a computer is a solid made
of silicon and some additives to that
and it's like every atom is in its place
but the question is if you're in a
liquid for example where all these
molecules are sloshing around and they
can they can interact with each other
they can have a chemical reactions and
so on is there a way to do computation
with all those molecules on a liquid by
looking at certain attributes of
collections of molecules not just the
concentration of some particular kind of
molecule but some other details about
how these molecules are kind of
sort of bouncing around on the liquid is
that a possible way to get computations
done i kind of suspect that it is and
that will open up a whole bunch of sort
of new nanotechnology-like things but
where the things we're doing don't
they're not immediate translations of
things that we've already been doing in
sort of large-scale machines
and i think that that um uh so
that that's that's a thing there now now
one of the one of the things that makes
nanotechnology very very potentially
valuable in addition to the fact that
well there's a it's molecules are quite
small and so
in a very tiny space using a very tiny
amount of energy one could potentially
have a lot of things done if one's doing
it at the level of individual molecules
so
another thing is that because biology
uses essentially nanotechnology-like uh
methodology to to
to do things with molecules if we want
to interface to biology we really need a
kind of nanotechnology solution if we
want to have a thing that's a piggyback
takes piggyback rides on red blood cells
or that goes in and uh
you know is a little machine that that
is a kind of a net
that goes in front of uh you know white
blood cells t or let's say t cells or
something and and looks you know let's
say it's a debugger for t cells that
tries to figure out you know stop that t
cell it's about to attack one of your
own tissues and give you an autoimmune
disease or something um you know stop
that t cell you know have it have sort
of a a backpack that pokes it and says
don't attack that tissue that was the
wrong thing to do and provide that as a
piece of technology so to speak that's
something for which we would have to
have kind of a nanotechnology solution
that can ride on the back of a t-cell so
to speak uh to be to be able to do that
and i think that's
a um uh that that's kind of a big
motivation for for doing the
nanotechnology i mean i think another
thing to say
is that something i've i've sort of
often thought imagining kind of the
future of things
is
uh there was uh right now you know we
have computers and there's you know 100
billion maybe a trillion computers in
the world that are you know in you know
any car has i know 50 computers or
something in it these days any you know
our even our phones have multiple
separate computers in them it's it's you
know there are computers all over the
place
and um uh but but there's still we think
of that being oh there's this number of
computers in something
well if we're able to do computation at
the level of molecules so to program
things at the level of molecules then no
longer will be saying there's this
number of computers in this thing but
rather we'll be saying this thing is
just made of computers instead of it
being the case that i have a you know a
plastic case for a for i don't know some
for something uh that is just an inert
piece of plastic it's like well actually
that case is
made of computers and it's all
programmable and so you know if you want
the case to display some weird pattern
it's all a programmable thing if the
molecules can get there it can be
programmed to do that so to speak and i
kind of think that's the ultimate kind
of version of nanotechnology is it kind
of
melts into just what everything is made
of that it is the case that in addition
to
things being there being computers that
are discrete computers there are also
things where sort of the whole molecular
structure of something is programmable
so now the next challenge is okay so how
do you program it what how might you
specify let's say you've got a thing and
it's got a trillion trillion molecules
in it
and it's possible to program those
molecules to do all sorts of things how
would you specify what you want
those um
uh what you want those molecules to do
and what in what kind of language would
you describe
what what kinds of things you want those
molecules to do now some many of the
things you want them to do are things
which are sort of collective and on a
large scale because that's what we
humans think about like put make the uh
you know the back of my cell phone case
have a um uh have a big kind of um
um
the um
have a uh
a giant um flashing blue dot or
something on it um that um uh
that would be um
uh that that's something that's sort of
a macroscopic scale that we humans can
immediately describe and understand but
something that is on a much smaller
scale maybe it's something we haven't
even thought is worth doing like make
that cell phone case roughen it in this
complicated way
so that uh you know water drops we'll do
this thing on it so that whatever it
becomes a a thing where we didn't even
think of that as being a thing you might
want to do
and so that's sort of the question it's
kind of a an interwoven issue of how do
you have a language to describe what you
want all those molecules to do
versus how do you imagine what you want
the molecules to do and obviously i've
spent a large part of my life as a
computational language designer so this
is this is the kind of thing i think a
lot about is how do you define a
language that
we can communicate with our computers
and and that is a way of describing uh
sort of things we want to have happen in
the world so that they're things that
where we understand what we want
but also they're things where we're kind
of crispening up those thoughts by
providing a framework that is based on
some sort of underlying let's say
computational ideas so that's a that's a
good challenge is this question of if
you could program everything if
everything was made of computers how
would you tell those computers what to
do and what kinds of things would you
say that what what kinds of operations
would you would you expect to be able to
do there and what kinds of sort of
conceptualizations would you have of
kind of what's happening you know we
have a hard time imagining what a
trillion trillion molecules do unless
all they're doing is collectively
producing a flashing blue dot um the uh
you know i think that that um uh that
that's a thing where it's a it's a
mixture of what's needed at the level of
conceptualizing the language and what's
needed at the level of imagining what's
possible and you know in a sense if you
were just throwing
a bunch of molecules and you know the
chemistry of the early earth
the concept that life is possible and
that you could have you know living
organisms running around you know live
streaming about living organisms and so
on that that is possible given only
those raw molecules that existed on the
early earth is
perhaps super surprising it would have
been hard to imagine if you saw the
early earth and you were asked imagine
what this could lead to imagine what uh
what kinds of things with these
molecules you could construct you would
have a very hard time doing that i think
and so now given the technology that
we're starting to have and given ideas
like nanotechnology imagining what what
could you conceivably construct from
this let's say let's say the whole earth
was covered with programmable stuff
what could you then do
what would that be like
what would you know we could in a sort
of
simple way we could say well then we
could reconfigure things you know
instead of having an object where we say
this is a blah
every object like when we say when we
talk about computers computers are
universally programmable in the sense
that given a computer you can feed it a
program that will make it run any
computation you want so it isn't the
case that we say we have a computer we
might have a computer that's specially
built to be optimized for something but
in general we have a computer that just
does computations it's not a computer
for adding it's not a computer for
streaming videos it's not a computer for
doing whatever it's just a computer
now today when we think about you know
objects that we hold in our hand or
whatever else
we say it's an object for doing such and
such typically but maybe there comes a
time when everything is programmable but
that's no longer the case where
everything is like a universal object so
to speak
and that's um now obviously biology has
not done that really it's done that a
bit dna is kind of an everything
molecule it can it can encode anything
proteins can have many different
structures they're kind of like
everything universal molecules but when
we look at the organization of actual
biological biological organisms
you know we all have you know separate
organs for doing this and that and the
other thing it's not the case that we
have the generic organ that does
everything i suppose the the closest we
have to things like that well brains
and and the immune system are are both
examples where they're sort of
everything organs that cover uh you know
that can be in a sense reconfigured to
do their programmable much like
computers are programmable they're
reconfigurable but you know it's sort of
an interesting exercise to imagine you
know imagine the whole earth is covered
in completely programmable molecules
what could conceivably happen what could
conceivably be possible and you know
imagine that you're confronted with a
planet that was set up that way it's
quite possible that the things you would
see there would be utterly
incomprehensible to us humans given the
current state of our development it's
kind of like uh uh
you know that that's a that's an
interesting thing that we we kind of um
um
uh
you know have
have to
imagining
something that is you know what tends to
happen in terms of our imagination in
terms of sort of progress in science and
technology
is we typically
you know it's a very incremental thing
we can imagine things that are a little
bit in front of where we are today if
we're if we're very if we're very good
at it we can imagine things a little bit
further away you know i think i think a
bunch of things that
um uh
um i am
uh
i i one of the things that's both a good
feature and a bad feature is i think i
can pretty much say that a bunch of
things that well i've done last 40 years
or so and i've worked on are sort of
things that most naturally are 50 or 100
years in the future
and that sounds really cool except for
the fact that it's also really
frustrating because it's like look this
is what's going to happen okay will
today you know pay attention to what's
going to happen
well you know you can kind of see i've
been around long enough to be able to
see these trends of yes the thing i
thought was going to happen yep it's
been happening
but it's kind of like pulling that
artifact from the future into today is a
very challenging thing for which uh uh
it's it's sort of a i'm in a sense
perhaps i'm personally more interested
in building the artifacts from the
future than i am in sort of telling the
world today what those artifacts in the
future are going to be although i
certainly make some effort to do that
but i think this is a thing where where
if we imagine you know we sort of start
imagining the
the incremental progress i will say that
that one of the features of uh is an
interesting story of of science
discovery actually
um one of the things that sort of a
success story of nanotechnology are
these things called buckyballs
named after buckminster fuller and a big
enthusiast of gdc domes these things
that are kind of soccer ball like shapes
where you're making um you're making
something which is like a like a bit of
a like a sphere or a hemisphere out of
combinations of of hexagons and
pentagons um but in any case the the
thing that people guessed at some point
in the
70s or 80s
is that you could actually make
uh molecules in which carbon atoms were
arranged like the kind of the like the
the sort of seams in a um in a soccer
ball that you could make a cage of
carbon atoms that was arranged in like
the pieces of a geodesic dome
and people were trying to figure out how
would we do that oh it's very hard we've
got to synthesize it in this way we
arrange the molecule in this way and
that way and the other way it turns out
your average
soot
that gets produced in uh in a fire
has tons of buckyballs in it it's just
nobody knew to look for them and it
wasn't so easy to look because like
they're just molecules and you have to
have all these techniques of x-ray
crystallography and so on to study you
know the shape of the molecules um but
that was uh but so now it's become clear
that that right under our noses forever
there was this form of carbon in
addition to the standard ones of
graphite and diamonds there was this
form of carbon that was these kind of
cages carbon cages but okay so that was
sort of an early
uh thought of as kind of an early
application of of um
nanotechnology because there are
actually other things you can make out
of nets of out of collections of carbon
atoms for example another thing you can
make is is carbon nanotubes and they
have wonderful properties of electrical
conductivity and and so on of um uh of
just these things where you're just
making it they're very strong they're
extremely strong materials when people
have imagined making a um a thing that
you could just uh lasso satellites in
orbit you could just have a you know a
cable that connects uh the surface of
the earth to a satellite in
geostationary orbit for example people
have imagined that that's a very hard
thing to do because you need a very
strong material to be able to do that
but carbon nanotubes sort of woven
carbon nanotubes are sort of the best
hope right now for being able to do
something like that but that's a that's
a kind of material that is made by by
thinking about things at the level of
molecules and just sort of building this
structure that's a little bit like a
large scale sort of woven structure but
it's done at the level of molecules so
that was kind of a success story for the
concept of nanotechnology but i have to
say that in the in the first instance
the um the early kind of buckyball stuff
the main thing i think that came out of
that was kind of the non-stick a new
generation of non-stick frying pans and
and things like this that seemed like a
bit of a mundane outcome from such a
lofty kind of concept like
nanotechnology but there's more to come
no doubt with carbon nanotubes and so on
i mean i would say that this is one of
the the interesting challenges with
science in general is you know you know
a piece of science okay how are you
going to use that technologically you
know you discover
that
let's say
um
certain
let's say you discover
there's a material where if you put a
magnetic field in it it will uh stop
transmitting light in the same way okay
so what that's an interesting effect but
so what what are you going to do with
that
well you have to then understand how do
you connect that scientific effect with
something that has some human purpose
that that we humans care about and it's
been sort of a strange thing because for
example if you look at different
chemical elements i don't know tantalum
dysprosium you know all sorts of obscure
well maybe niobium less obscure you know
these all these different of the of the
100 or so chemical elements
um that 90 or so stable chemical
elements that exist it's like well which
ones out there in the world are useful
for which purposes and what's become
clear is oh well actually
you know gadolinium somewhat obscure uh
element oh that's a really good thing
for making very strong magnets out of
et cetera et cetera et cetera and um uh
in as new technologies come online
whether it's the electric car technology
stack with different kinds of batteries
and so on or whether it's computers or
whether it's various kinds of
telecommunications types of things as
those different technology stacks come
online
so these these materials and elements
where people are saying what is this
good for you know it it's some uh
um it's it's kind of a it's sort of a um
that gets discovered because the
technology kind of arrives
and and connects
and i find it kind of interesting that
you know there are mineral deposits
around the earth in different places and
you know some countries got lucky with
oil some countries got lucky with you
know with niobium some countries got
lucky with tantalum and it's uh i have
noticed i've been i've been saying this
to people from various countries at
various times that that you know if you
happen to have big deposits of thing x
then go encourage people to research
what is x good for and i was quite
amused that i i saw for the first time
an ad promoting that for a somewhat
obscure uh from a somewhat obscure
element from a particular country um
that because it's an obvious thing to do
if you if your country has tons of of
mineral deposits of that particular
thing which people say well that's nice
but who cares um it's like if it turns
out there's actually technology for
which if you you know if you kind of go
from the technology end and from the
science end you realize oh wow that's an
incredibly valuable and useful thing
that's sort of a big win it's a it's a
way of taking something it's it's sort
of a a general thing when you have in
that case not a science but but natural
resources that you know can you make it
more valuable by by kind of
understanding its connection to
technology
um
all right well i think i should wrap up
there so um
thanks for
joining me and um
i'll uh be back again next week and
please uh do send us i think we have a
way of sending
uh
in questions
that uh or topics
um that we can accumulate
through the week
um and i will try to address here
and uh i will say that
i i always enjoy doing these
because uh
i it really helps me to kind of try to
explain
these various different ideas and
concepts and so on and they're um
uh
uh
it's um
uh it's very helpful to me so i hope
people find it interesting to hear about
these things and um i guess on the on
the live stream chat
um we will be taking some feedback and
questions for a little while here i
would also like to ask a general
feedback question which is there are
some other platforms
that we have considered using to also
stream these live streams on
and um if
you've got suggestions about other
platforms that will be more convenient
for you please let us know because we're
uh
you know i'm sitting here and doing my
thing and uh sort of the um the bits are
getting streamed out to as many places
as as is practical
so let us know if there are other ones
that will be helpful
all right well thanks for